Hello. Welcome to Rawkode Live.
Today is part one of three of a
clustered KubeCon special.
We're mixing things up a little bit today
and doing it slightly differently
than we have done in the past. I
hope you all enjoy the new format.
Feel free to leave comments as we go,
but do our best to get them on
the screen and so forth. Now before we
get started, there's a little bit of housekeeping.
First, please subscribe to the YouTube if you
haven't already. Also remember to click the bell.
That way you'll get notifications whenever I go
live covering clustered
or any of the other cloud native technologies
out there that we'll be doing learning materials
on.
If you're not watching live or even if
you are, but you just like to chat,
join us in the Discord at Rawkode.chat.
There's now almost 300 of us in there
talking cloud native Kubernetes and everything in between.
So come and say hello.
And lastly, I wanna thank my employer, Equinix
Metal. They allow me to do this on
their time, which is great. They provide the
resources for me to use for all of
these many, many clusters also. So thank you
very much Equinix Metal. You can check it
out with the code Rawkode.
This will get you $200 That's up to
four hundred hours of bare metal compute. Check
it out, have some fun and let me
know how you get on.
Alright. Like I said, today we are mixing
things up a little bit. This is not
breakers well, it is breakers versus fixers, but
a slightly different format. I am joined by
Walid and Noel. We have all brought a
broken cluster with us today, and we're gonna
pair up and fix where the breaker laughs
at us along the way. If we need
any help, I'm sure we'll all be helpy.
We'll all be happy to throw in some
advice as well. So first, hey, Noel. Hey,
Walid. How are you both?
Hi. Hey, good. How are you? I know.
I just said like hello to you both,
and then, like, give you the opportunity to
fight each other to say hello back. So
no. Why don't you say hello and tell
us a little bit about you first?
Yep.
CubeCon week, so deprived of sleep. That's our
only downside,
and otherwise, I'm doing good
and, like, catching up all the talks and
being in the hallway section.
Yeah. Definitely. A really packed week. So much
going on just now. So hopefully, this gives
you a little bit of a a break
from all the talks and a little bit
of fun in between.
Walid, say hello and let us know who
you are, please.
Hey, everybody.
I'm Walid,
the cloud native janitor. I'm still early in
my journey to cloud native,
watching David videos as I am,
and he's
and hoping to learn something today.
Awesome.
Well,
we have
three clusters.
We we've each broken one.
And we're gonna start with cluster 19,
which is Waleed's cluster. So Noel and I
will be taking point on this and trying
to debug our way to get this cluster
happy and healthy.
Walid, we'll let you know if we need
any advice,
but I'm sure this is gonna be
very interesting.
I'm curious to see just how many ways
we can break clusters. Like, there's one thing
that continues to amaze me with every episode
of clustered is that we're always seeing new
weird ways of breaking the system.
Alright. Noel. And probably after watching some talks,
like, over this, you've gone, I probably have
more ideas.
Yeah. Hopefully, keep going has given us all
a little bit of advice to try and
fix these things.
I'm gonna join onto the control plane of
Wally's cluster. If you can join that session,
please know.
Yeah. And just type echo hello. Let us
know that you're there. There's mine.
And I'm sure Wally just made this nice
and easy for us as well. Right?
Use cube control. So
Alright. I didn't even use Carol.
Alright. Let's just get our setup working with
the Kubernetes clusters. We'll just export the cube
config.
We'll do alias k. Otherwise, I'm gonna be
typing on MacMod all day. And then, Noel,
I will give you the honors of running
get nodes or get pods whenever you wish.
Oh, I'll just have that auto completion.
And the completion. I always forget about the
completion.
Yes.
Oh, what did I do?
Oh, it's on the Yes, Lewis.
Yeah. Completion bash. Right? We're learning from you,
Lewis.
Glad and typing.
That's because you're being watched.
Look at that.
We have a control plan. Thank you, Vallid.
We appreciate that.
It looks like we have one worker node
offline.
We just check-in our
yeah. Go for it. I'm just describe
it to see if it's like something obvious.
Oh,
come on.
Oh.
So we got an access for Ben on
describing
in node.
RBAC. Oh, I see Wow.
I thought this was a CKE
issue.
All right. So
I mean, taking down one of our our
work and all that's obviously a problem. Shall
we check to see if our workload pod
is also running? Just to see if there's
more than one issue.
There's Yep. Three issues.
Three issues. Alright. Let's do a get pods.
Alright. Our postgres has been terminating for a
rather long time. I suspect that probably because
the node. Yep. That's not ready probably.
Yeah. That's what I'm thinking too.
Yeah. Okay.
Yep.
That's what you think. And not yep.
What's it like just sitting there and getting
to watch a sweat a little while you
do? Is it good on that side of
the fence?
You know,
you laugh last, no? Anyway.
Alright. So I've opened
a shell on the broken worker, if you
wanna join that.
And we'll we'll start debugging.
Just give me an echo or something when
you're there.
Did you join, or did you start a
new session?
I my Firefox is acting weird. I can't
see the other taps. It's kind of like
even better.
Alright. I'll poke around just now while you
sort that out. So first thing I'm gonna
look for might have to close and rejoin.
Yep. Give me a minute. Like, I just
picked in and rejoined. You take your time.
I'm just gonna poke around right now. So
I'm just checking the
status of our system d service for the
kubelet. It appears to be loaded, enabled, but
dead.
I wonder,
I'm just gonna try the completely naive thing
first but I'm just gonna restart it.
I guess we're pulling up oh, where's my
You're not on the controller blink. You're in
the node.
Yeah. I was just seeing a Your your
muscle memory is working here.
So
this is I saw some I saw some
folks basically asking that they wanted to watch
this for doing the CKA,
and I watched you and and the CTF
saying that
what brought this ID was the CKN, CKAD
troubleshooting. So I said, okay. Let's have some
CKA troubleshooting session.
So this would be simple.
Okay.
Well, it appears.
There we go. We have no back.
Great.
I always make the mistake that I sometimes
I think complicated,
but
things I
learned from Lewis from control plane that thinks
think simple first.
We have some might.
We have We do have some errors. Right?
We do. So we I restarted the kubelet.
It's now running, which is good. I don't
know why I was p s a u
x and grabbing for API server because I'm
I'm silly. But the kubelet is running, and
and we do have some errors that we
probably
Oh. Check.
That's, I think, fine
because oh, let's see if the ceiling ports
are running.
Yeah. We'll do that from the control plan,
I guess. So oh, sorry. On you go.
You just take I've
it's all yours.
It's not cube system. Right? But I'll just
check just in case.
I guess it's called CapEx. So
the first issue was fixed in less than
ten minutes. That's very good.
Alright. It looks like we have a
I've got quite a few pending things going
on here. Do you wanna describe one of
those pendings?
Yep. Oh,
man.
Alright. Can get the pods, but I can't
describe it.
Strange. So
Okay. So we need to Especially the guy
watching KubeCon.
Okay. So we let's do a
kube control
off.
Can I list?
Yes. So for node, we don't have get
permissions.
And what so the
Alright.
Custer role.
But he have certificates and certificate signing requests.
I wonder what can you do with these.
Okay. So you haven't modified the cluster admin
role.
Role.
So Did I or didn't I? You'd well
I just opened it.
No. There is something called, like, a something
I found recently
about this
cluster role aggregation.
Right. Right? The policies can be actually merging
from a different role, but I don't think
it's happening here. So it's fine. It could
be an aggregation.
Could be. It couldn't.
I don't think I'm enjoying having a breaker
on the stream now.
This is fun. Yep.
I want to give a shout out to
Mark and his RR back session.
It was very helpful and
very
Oh, I missed it. Yeah. Never saw that
one. No. No. I'm really disappointed with myself,
man. Alright. Okay. So we
looked at the cluster admin rule, which I
believe is the one given to us by
Kubernetes.
So now we're gonna have to either take
a look at the system aggregates.
And there's no way to get modified times
on any of these unless
Oh, you can actually. If you scroll back.
Yeah. In the YAML. Yeah.
I was gonna get the YAML of all
of them and just kind of grep for
Oh,
what? Maybe not in cluster or maybe.
That was super helpful.
Okay.
So Let's get only one. Yep.
Let's confirm something. I'll I'll like to do
some type of note, and I'll just kind
of get some so it could be a
cluster role, but we haven't actually tested to
see if the describe
was all namespaces or not. We tried Selium
and cube system. Do you want did we
try default as well?
I think we did. We tried to describe
Postgres.
Maybe. So you are on the right track,
by the way. So
if I do this,
it shows up
and describe.
I don't care which board.
So this is happening at a cluster level.
So it's like app app yeah. So it's
all applicable across the namespace, everything.
Okay. So
And when we did the role, cluster role.
Right? Let me just look at it again
just to confirm we didn't miss anything.
I mean, all I see are scars.
This doesn't have the last applied configuration and
rotation. I think that might be, like, for
cluster roles. It would actually tell us, like,
when it was modified at least.
I haven't played with that one. Alright.
So let's take a look at
do we see edits in the event log?
Do wanna try kubectl get events?
Sneaky.
Okay. Let's go through the system rules and
actually work out what we have access to.
So I think we should start by taking
a look at first admin, and then we'll
do the aggregation.
Yep. So we did it. Look at we
did look at the admin. Right? So let's
But we looked at cluster admin, but not
just admin.
Remember,
I was inspired by capture the flag and
by Mark session.
I wish I had seen Mark's our back
session, but I didn't.
Okay.
So let's do edit cluster rule. Oh,
no. Off you go. Sorry. Just a minute.
I just want to confirm if this is
actually, like, the cluster admin itself.
And something Rory said on his session with
you, David.
Okay. This was not modified.
Let me give you a hint.
How about cluster role binding? Maybe they would
Ah.
Let you let you come closer.
Hello. It's on the same issue, mate. I
wish I could remember the CTF. It feels
like a it feels like a month ago.
Ah, so in the cluster on binding, we
might be given a different service account.
Okay. So we should probably take a look
at the customer admin binding and see if
the roles are sent through. On the
on this now? This one here.
I'm still looking through. There's a 50 layer.
Okay.
Kubernetes.
Let's not delete it. So let's see, actually.
No. Don't delete anything. Yep.
I I I like delete sledgehammer approach. So
Check first before deleting.
Yep. So for the Kubernetes admin user,
add cluster sys admin.
Oh, let's describe cluster oh, we can't describe.
Let's edit cluster sys admin or get all
YAML.
Yep. In fact, we don't need to scrape.
Could just be doing get all YAML and
everything probably to get around the the scrape.
What
is it called? Cluster sys admin. Cluster sys
admin.
There we go. See? Yep. So it's, like,
limited. So we just need to update the
role binding to just use a system
sorry. Cluster admin. I think we can just
delete the role binding, and we should be
No. No. Don't delete the role binding. If
you delete the role binding, you'll miss the
hints. There are hints somewhere here.
Oh, you've you've taken this on a journey,
are you? Okay. There is a flag
as Lewis said. Oh.
Alright. Let's take a look at that rule
binding again.
Maybe not the rule binding, but it starts
okay.
Alright. Look. There's an original fail. No. I
was just thinking so if we just Do
you see the annotation? No?
Ah.
Come on.
So it looks like
it's in slash e t c slash Kubernetes.
Think
slash e t c slash Kubernetes.
Ordinary file slash honk?
Okay. I don't think there's a honk in
there, but it might be somewhere else.
Dot honk.
L s slash dot honk.
And a honk too.
Don't look at the honk too yet.
Alright. So you have created a new user
with rule binding and swapped out Yeah. I
created the new rules there,
but I didn't give him the group. Yeah.
So Yes.
But the file times
but wait. Didn't we export it to default
one?
And the file doesn't seem to be
You you modify this the
this timestamp on it. I yeah. I don't
yep.
Never mind. I just want to confirm it's
actually saying Kubernetes admin. Yep. Anyway, so what
I will do is give better
dash q config.admin.conf.
It's Good.
Lewis, you'll be on the Caesar's stream soon.
So
So we could just switch to the default.
I I had a challenge because, basically, the
Kubernetes administrator is part of system masters.
And
you cannot
basically redefine the roles for sys for Kubernetes
administrator because system master is in the code.
You cannot change it.
So I have to
basically
override it.
Okay.
So now we should be to able to
cube cuddle,
describe
no. I just get the note because
we don't did we fix that? Oh oh,
that was fixed. Why does that wait?
One issue per ten minutes. That's great.
Yep. Q cuddle minus and cilium.
Get pods.
Alright. So we still need to describe these
and work out why they're pending. Yeah.
Hi, Philip. Hi.
Come on. I suspect we really wanna look
at honk too soon.
No. Don't, please. I
don't know it is in honk too, actually.
It's it's not yet even scheduled.
I'm sorry. I was too busy. It was
in last Right?
It didn't even get scheduled. It's still, like,
in a pending stage, like, there are no
events or anything.
Okay. So it's not been scheduled. Yeah. You're
right. So the scheduler may be done. Wanna
check for a scheduler in cube system?
Yep.
Gosh. Oh, look. It's not there. Okay. One
of the
oh, we don't have a schedule there. Yeah.
Let's go check the static manifest.
Let's see. Kubernetes
manifest.
And let's get it. Oh,
come on.
We
do have a group contributor, but it's not
running.
It's probably the mount okay. Let's look at
c r I cuddle just to make sure,
like, it's probably c r I cuddle dash
dash
runtime
endpoint.
It's working. It's working. C r I cuddle.
It I fixed it for you. So you
have I am very nice So
the cube scheduler is not running, so we
can actually lock.
There's two. There's one running and one exit
it.
Okay.
So let's
but it didn't register itself. So
Well, it's not showing up. I hate these
silly things on Linux, like, not able to,
like, copy paste.
Just go to varlog containers.
Yep. It's Rback.
Oh,
Rback again.
Mark session must be very good.
Alright. Let's pop open the cube scheduler
and check the service account.
Oh, come on. Stop. Yep. Okay. Cube scheduler.
Yes. Does it has a service account associated
with that?
No. It doesn't. But it uses a volume
on. So
Yeah. The schedule.com.
Okay. Let's go check that file.
Authentication. Yep. That's the authentication file it uses.
Yep. Now those two have the same file.
So Etsy, Kubernetes, should do that account. B
Etsy. You're smashing this now. I've got faith
in you.
Should do that account.
I have I am successful. I see you
guys.
Oh, so this must be, like, a similar
one.
So they're all binding for a system cube
scheduler
with the different one probably. So you'll check
other
cat. No. No. No. This is fine.
Ah,
okay. I wanted to change it, but that's
this one is fine.
But it has some hints also.
Not my hints. Yeah.
Certificate of RT.
Let's Yeah.
Is the cluster name correct? I just want
to confirm. Yep.
It looks for it. Yeah. But
what was the error message again?
I don't know. We don't pay attention to
it.
That was, like, too long. So I can't
do that. That sense. I don't know. Does
that work?
Actually, we could just oh, man. This is
like so
it says
fail to watch. So the watch permission is
mostly missing.
Oh, there we go.
And what else it says?
It is telling us that the cluster role
system keep scheduler is not found.
Okay.
So we should look at a cluster. Right?
So let's look at the custom. I pay
his renamed
error. So this is
remake,
by the way.
If you remember,
I don't know which cluster was it.
But Phil did the same thing, but you
fixed it by mistake.
So I wanted to see why it was
fixed by mistake.
So if you edit the Kube API server
and
add our back and remove it again or
something,
there are certain roles gets recreated.
Yep. Because those are, like, admin things. Right?
Yes. The because they are built in.
So I deleted the role,
and it's in
oh, man. It it did it get created
again? No. No. That's the volume scheduler. Yeah.
You're So the the so the role is
in the hunk hunk two folder.
Yep. I guess I mean but another way
to redo it is just edit the Kube
API server.
Alec loses the base. Make the same mistake
twice. And just let it complete.
Right? Thanks
for saving the manifest. Yeah. We appreciate that.
Yeah. Let's just apply that then. I can
just do you gotta
apply that.
Just I think that's useful to share and
make sure we we get that across to
everyone watching. What you're saying is if we
delete any of the core
cluster rules, if you remove authorization from the
API server and add it back, it will
recreate all of those rules.
Yeah. Why don't you try it?
Can we just restart the API server, or
do we actually need to disable authentic
authorization? It will restart. The moment you change
something, it will restart anyway.
I see Kubernetes manifest,
and I just need to touch it. Right?
No. No. You need to edit
it.
Let's try touching it and see if it
does it. I'm curious if just a restart
would do Yes. Okay. Yeah. Then we can
try that. Yes.
Go ahead, Noel.
That cube.
It's sure. Right? Yes.
Yeah. Rep.
I just API.
It's not. Not restarted yet. Give us a
second. It does it does take a click.
Yeah. It's like sometimes it takes a while.
That's what I've seen when I was breaking
clusters.
Would have killed my just named it by
now.
The bad point I think the recreation was
actually, we had a question about the same
thing in the chat, our Discord chat. Like,
someone lost the cluster admin role or something
in a case
cluster. They just restarted it, and it just
came back.
Yeah. Let's do Oh, it's a static manifest,
so I'll just kill it.
Last time I called this thing, got bad
stuff happened.
Let's not kill it. We could just do
CRC till, like, delete the board. Simple.
Let's just yeah.
Add an You touch it. Correct? We tried
that. It doesn't we try to do anything.
So we'll add a label. It should, at
least. There we go. Oh, there we go.
I think you broke your own cluster now.
No.
There we go. No. We
shit. No. This would take a little bit
of time.
We go.
Nope. It came back up. Right? It takes
a little bit of time.
The watch is faster,
but,
it's here.
Alright. So that's really cool to know. By
restarting the API server, any core RBAC stuff
will be fixed for you. That's awesome. I
like that.
And that was the unintentional
fix you did with Phil, I mean.
I'll take as many unintentional fixes as I
can. Wonder if it has any security implications.
Right? I don't know where the default roles
are stored. If we could actually, like, manipulate
that, it means, like, if someone restart, like,
a malicious something could come up. Right?
Yes. Now if you check, most likely, every
vending item
is running now.
Yep. Looks good.
Fixed it. Yep. Easy. Could you check the
Selium?
One thing I didn't understand
I mean, I killed all Selium, but they
still have
the network as the nodes as ready.
With other network plug ins, you will not
see network ready.
Yeah. CRM is probably doing
more I don't know. Is it running in
IP tables mode or, like, without the Q
proxy?
It is no. The Q proxy is saying
IBVFS.
I can I think I checked that? Yes.
Oh, okay.
Yeah. I think it's probably So you think
it's basically works. Right?
Yeah.
Alright.
Walid, have we fixed everything on this cluster?
Yeah. Yeah. Everything is done. So, basically, it
was two issues. Our back end assemble cubelet
was down.
Awesome. Well,
thank you for that. I don't have good
learning.
I always fear the
RBAC stuff, but it was we learned a
lot in that one. I really appreciate that.
Alright. Let's get let's jump into nulls. Well,
each of you can get that session up
and echo something else. It's terminal.
No. No.
Okay. So active sessions.
Alright. Let's see. Got a couple of Join
session.
Magna wants to see Andy lose their cluster.
We are gonna make that happen. Don't worry.
And Mahmoud says, hey. What's up, Alit?
Hey, Mahmoud.
GitHub ing, man.
That's
what happens when you don't have GitHub. Alright.
Let's get the basics set up. I really
should just bake this into the provisioning steps.
Alright. Well, it will give you the honors
of the get nodes, get pods, whatever you
fancy.
Okay.
Complete.
Oh, the completion.
Yeah.
We need the
I still don't understand how batch completion works.
It's a mistake. Oh, he didn't do it.
Just a second. Yeah. I thought he did.
No. I just did the a cube config
export and a key alias.
Okay.
I don't think that worked.
I didn't?
It says dash command not found. I'm assuming
no has messed with our kubectl binary.
Yeah. He is. Oh.
Oh, we haven't broke Okay. No.
We have a broken control plane. So that
means the completion doesn't work? Really?
Yeah. Because it Maybe?
Yeah.
It needs to talk to something, isn't it?
Just gotta check something before we
take.
Thank you, Noah. Not that I don't trust
you,
Honk, man.
How many counts? We're going to rec roll
us on cluster. That is harsh.
That's it.
So this is looking for a count equals
three.
Yep.
You might want to, like, close the session
and rejoin.
It messes a little bit with the terminal.
So I think the session today is called
don't trust.
Or whoever gives you anything, command configuration file,
don't trust it. Double check. Exactly.
Yep. Exactly. Because I knew that the completion
command doesn't require
a working
server.
So
And that's why the completion didn't work. Yeah.
So we need to download.
Or you have You don't need to download.
If you play I played nice. If you
look in there, you'll find it maybe.
Okay.
Can we look at the script again?
If there was nothing in the script, it
tells where it was, and then I deleted
it.
No. It doesn't. But just grab for some
similar keywords.
Not cube,
maybe cuddle. Just cuddle.
Maybe honk.
Honk CTL.
Honk CTL. Yeah. It's a nice CTL, by
the way.
Okay. That's better. Or list list them by
time.
We have a working cube control now.
Okay. Good. Yep. That's fixed. So the first
issue is fixed. It looks like I lost
my connection.
Oh, yeah. You'll have to join the other
session because no work loaders.
Oh, the Yeah. It's outside.
I always do that. Oh. Okay.
Okay.
Why don't you go, Ravi? Go Go ahead.
No. No. Thanks.
You got
the completion.
Thanks,
chat.
We got no laughing. So
we fixed the first issue or not? No?
Complete. First issue is fixed.
How many issues we have?
Probably three or four.
I didn't really count.
So, basically,
like, when you said, like, before, right, we
canceled the session. So that time, I actually
got time to play with it. So I
just had, like, a script ready and, like,
did some breakage. I never touched it again.
Alright.
So that
already looked wrong. Yep.
It's trying to connect the local host 8080.
So I think he's I think Noel has
modified our I didn't think No. I didn't
touch it. No. No. Sorry. Sorry. Sorry. You're
not
exporting it. Got it.
Yep.
Cool.
Lewis, master rec role.
Pardon me.
What do we have?
So we have one more. I don't like
by
product of my speech. I didn't touch Yeah.
Any of that group thing. So it might
be a byproduct of the other breakages I
did. So could be.
I didn't touch it. That's
Well, it looks like clustered and postgres are
both running on the default namespace. So I
guess we should just be upgrading clustered to
see if we can get the new version.
But let's look at this why it's not
starting.
Let
I let's not waste time on talking about
that. I don't think Node touched that. Yeah.
Okay. Yeah. I didn't touch it. So yep.
So
let's follow the usual things that we usually
do.
We're gonna roll it restart first. It's just
called clustered deployment clustered.
Yep.
And if that works, we should just be
able to upgrade it.
It looks like a timeout.
Just wait a minute.
Yeah. Yeah. I wait wait for my time
out because they can provide actually
meaningful message.
Failed to batch.
Cluster is forbidden. Not yet ready to handle
request. That's nice. That's new to me.
So this is a very nice thing I
found out. Yeah. It's nice. Like it.
Okay.
So
And just to be
what?
Nice. I didn't touch our back.
Sorry?
Just
to be nice, I'm giving you a hint.
I didn't touch our back.
Yeah. Yeah.
I know you are a nice guy, Noel.
Okay.
So what's the problem here?
Let's get once again.
Yeah.
And okay. Let's see. So could this be
an admission control?
Mean, the failed if it was an admission
controller, maybe.
Let let's check for mutating webhooks and validating
webhooks, I guess. Okay. Get
Mutating webhook configurations and
yeah.
Yeah. The auto oh, yeah. K. Yeah. Queue
catalog.
Why is it not completion? No. It's called
mutating.
Well, the style is getting unmuting, and I
probably broke the completion because I'm a terrible
programmer.
That's okay, though. Wow.
That's strange.
Everything mutating that code configuration if you want
to, like, type custom session? Okay. Oh, sorry.
Can type it. Mutating
that code configuration.
Get.
Yep.
There we go. We got a honk.
Yes.
Can we edit it? See what what did
he do inside?
Yeah. I I think oh, sorry. I'll take
it too, Balit.
Oops. I forgot I'm not in there. Resent
them. Bad. I don't know why the auto
completion is not working,
but, yeah, it's, like,
tricky to work with all the extra CRDs
if auto completion is not working. Prior, they've
been all swapped out bash for dash. That's
what it is.
I know. I didn't do a go that
route. Okay.
Let's see the Let me see and see
from the
rules. Create update. Oh, you're running it on
your own server. Sneaky.
Yep.
I
mean, I think it's safe just to change
the failure policy on that to
Avail allow? What what is it? I don't
see. Fail or
ignore?
Ignore. I I I think ignore.
Or we could just delete the web hook.
I'm not fussy either way.
Okay.
Yeah. Let's just let's You might want to
rethink that. What? Why?
Is it if you got finalized or done
stuff?
No.
But it's something
yep. Alright. Hold on. Let's just It doesn't
look rotating. Webhook
configuration. Yeah. Let's look at the documentation.
It's fail or ignore, I think. But It's
enabled here. Match labels, honk enabled. So
name selector.
Feature policy failed. So, basically Yeah.
Ignore. Here we go. Oh, ignore. Let's make
it ignored. Yep.
Okay. And
Yeah. If we just save that. It again.
We should be able to
do that rollout command. Yeah.
Interesting.
So basically, he's changing any deployment that we
recreate
or and he's doing it for deployments. Yep.
Well, I think we still got something else
to find because this is taking too long
for Woah.
Yep. Why? This is I found this by
accident.
It does, like deployment in our cluster is
forbidden. Not yet ready to handle request.
Maybe
okay. Think it might take some time. Or
two before
no. It doesn't. It's something's not yet.
I'll give a hint. I'll wait for a
minute, and then I'll give a hint.
No. Those are validating.
Okay.
Actually,
I just want to check.
Okay. A cube control,
get events,
get events minus a, and all namespaces. No
resources found because it's over an hour, I
guess.
Can we go check out the
static manifest for the API server to see
if there's any other static admission controllers?
Yeah.
Checkpoint.
Check the time. By the way, he didn't
check the time there.
But I think maybe he will do the
same thing. He will touch them with the
old time.
I think that's gonna be a common name
in all customers. Maybe.
Most likely. I know you know him.
Okay.
So we have our back. And
Search for admission.
Oh, there we go. Admission. And Oh, yeah.
It's just normal, though.
Or is it?
Mutation admission web mode.
Okay. What else?
Okay. So I have mode restrictions,
indicating admission work and validation work, which is
okay. Oh, I think those are on by
default. Thought you would think they need to
list it.
I just called yep. Just read through it
and see if you find anything. There we
go. Run
time config. What's the run time config? Admins,
mission registration.
Okay. Man, you're thinking there. I think we
can call it now.
Yeah. Yep. So if you either make it
true or delete it,
the mutating repo could start working.
It's okay.
They do this for the beta ones and
the alpha ones. Yeah.
And Yep. API server.
It didn't do Yeah. It will take a
minute.
It will take a bit. Yeah?
Yeah. It will take, like, around ten, twenty
seconds. Yep. It's back. Okay.
Let's try again. There we go. Okay.
Thank you. No.
Get
bots minus eight.
Oh, no. I don't need to.
Okay. So it's running. The bot screen is
running. You want to do your
You
actually missed by restarting, you actually missed one
thing I put it in there, but it's
fine.
Well, we have an error image pool, so
it's not vain.
Oh, okay.
View control.
Describe.
What?
So how do I do this copy?
Or it should be clustered six seven.
You could, like, select, select, right click, copy,
paste.
GSHR,
Freshbow. Ah. Alright.
So we need set our those Yeah. I
we
started
No.
So
There's too much Rick Astley on this episode.
Don't know. Lewis gave me a lot of
Rick Astley.
Yeah.
He's a bad influence.
Yep. Bad influence.
Yeah. Lewis is saying the next episode of
Cluster he is involved with will be named
Untitled Rawkode.
I'm signing up for it. Let's do it.
So so
we should change this image to what? To
Rawkode
clustered colon v two.
Is it where is it? Here?
Also in GitHub? Rawk. Yep. Yep. Slash Cluster.
Rawkode
Cluster.
And tag v two.
Why did it move?
Yep. It happens.
But then I don't know why Vim does
that. Like, I always have to fix it.
Two more? Oh, one more. Two more. It's
not fixed yet. Yeah. The image needs to
go back. Yeah. One more level back. Vim
does something funky when you edit it. Yep.
Delete two more spaces so the hyphen is
in left the c. Yeah. That's it. Mhmm.
Yep. Perfect.
And you'll need to delete the
oh, I mean yeah. You'll need to delete
that. Oh, you might need to do a
port forward on the running one.
Oh, did you change the current image as
well?
Maybe.
I thought forward. The
postgres one, you mean? The postgres one? No.
I think The other one that's running.
Right? The one that's running, just your port
forward. Yeah. Yeah. It it
will not
Then let's come back to the error image
policy.
Yeah. Let me pull up the terminal. Let's
do that port forward so we can see
what what all this dropped on us.
This is three seconds.
I I
oh, just a second. Roll out.
We need to give it a different version.
Was it version two before?
Version one before. Version
one. Okay. Did you change the portal?
I had seen support,
but I did something. Yeah.
Just wait until it fails.
You might get some idea.
And Darren from Rancher is giving me this
idea.
From when?
Darren.
Right? From Rancher.
So he was doing a deep dive on
K3S, and I learned about
that thing, why port forward is not working.
Yep. Just hold on a bit so it
actually shows you the error. Don't cancel it
yet.
Oh, wow.
So the error here, it says that it's
the same image as before, but I I
so we did the rollout. So the rollout
should take us to
No. Let's come back to the rollout
the next thing. Otherwise, we would actually miss
out a thing I did. So let's fix
the port forward maybe first.
I didn't touch the replica sets.
He didn't touch that. Yep. So assess the
error we should be seeing? Unable to upgrade
connection? Yep. That's our that should give you
a hint.
Should it?
Yep.
I can see the error. So how does
bot forward work?
Bot forward, it's
reverse. No?
Reverse.
Yep. So how does it work?
The the the message we got, I'll I'll
just paste here so you can see it.
When I do the port forward to my
local machine is that.
Bot forward is basically connecting to the directly
to the IP of the bot.
So
it it will not use a service.
It will connect Like, is doing the bot
flow, like, from the host?
It could proxy. Right?
No?
Yep. Just look at the error and the
port number. You might get a hint.
So 1025O
is the
read only port number for the API server?
The cube the q no. For the cubelet.
For the cubelet.
So this So how port forward works is,
basically,
it actually goes to hit that Qubelet API
on 1250.
It uses that port number to the port
forward.
This is also how
Kubernetes
does some kind of help text and stuff.
So 12 1 0 2 5 0 should
be open.
And is it open? That's a question.
Well, I'm gonna assume not.
So you're made on the Cubelet?
System control.
Not nothing to do with the Cubelet. It's
just log in the board and Probably IP
tables or firewall. Stock. Are you playing with
the IP tables and stuff?
Or UFW?
Do you wanna just stop UFW, and then
we can or or we could just check
IP tables. Yeah.
Yep.
You're on the wrong host.
This is a control key. It doesn't matter.
Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes.
Get bots minus. Oh, wait.
So which host it is? This host,
which is WorkerRQH4M.
Okay. There's a session on that device open.
You can join it. Okay.
I'll just take your IP tools command.
Oh, look at that. I've got a drop.
Yep.
Should I give hint hint on how to
delete? Or are you I could just flush
it, or did you persist it?
No. I didn't process, like, just that entry.
Yeah. You can just flush it. There we
go.
You might need to do it on all
that work and not Yeah. It's working there.
Yeah.
Wanted to stay from host controls.
Yes. Oh, doesn't it play?
That's sad. Oh, it's it's it's Firefox.
Yeah. Firefox, I don't know why it just
seems to struggle.
I know you need to operate a new
port forward. I don't know why it happens.
Like, if a Firefox gets stuck
I
didn't
oh,
that's sad.
Next time another Rectrol, by the way.
Yep. But it was another withdrawal. Scream.
Okay. So we've flushed the IP tables. We
can now do a rollout.
No. We need to fix this. Why
yep. Try describing it again.
That's the old image.
Yep.
So who is changing the image on the
fly?
We have the whole CTF team, by the
way. We have Lewis. We have Andy.
We have Magnum. Nice.
So something is changing in the image.
And it wasn't a mutate and wipe it
because we deleted all of them. Right?
But it's it's it's still referring to the
old system.
Oh, no. We don't still need log in.
Have Yep.
Yep. Just delete it. It's fine.
Yeah. We only told it we had allowed
it to fail. So that was actually doing
two things. You sneak It was actually valid
endpoint.
It was not, like, something yeah. I actually
wrote a webhook.
Actually, it's actually very easy to write one.
I didn't realize it was very easy to
write one. It, like, probably takes, like, fifteen
to twenty minutes. Like, you can find samples
and just modify stuff.
Okay. Now you could probably do the rollout
restart or edit the deep silence.
Need to connect.
K pirate symbol.
What happened there?
Oh, I'm trying to get one.
Yeah.
There we go.
Yeah. That was
a brittle combination Strange. Issues there. Although we're
still getting our image pool error.
Yep. Why?
We deleted the mutating webhook.
Yep. This is Now we should have the
right image. Okay.
But the problem is
Not found.
Faint to resolve reference.
Okay. So did you play with the container's
configuration?
Registry
is like
no. You don't have it.
Go. You're on the right track.
Okay. So you have maybe web web
what is it called? Okay.
Can you get the resources? Let's get the
resources.
No. No. Go back. Back. It was right
on the track, checking the container d stuff.
Let's pop open that config.
Okay.
Config.
Because in actually, in cluster, they don't have
the configuration.
Okay. Login. Next. So go into that search
dot d.
So cc containers,
search of the
and s minus m.
Six. Man, I think with that. Just check
the search dot d thing. Maybe you'll get
a hint. Yeah.
What was it? The search .d?
Yep. Search.d.
Just a second.
Containers d. The search oh, it doesn't exist?
It does exist.
Okay.
And s.
Not access.
CT into it?
Yep. That's CT.
I am in the right one. I am
in the control plane.
But I am on the control plane.
Yep. So where is CD's getting pulled?
Sorry?
Yep. You are right.
Yeah. If we go through the worker node
that we had opened earlier, but it there's
a GHCR override.
Okay. Let's connect to the other one, the
worker node.
Sneaking.
So if you
so this came out in continuity version one
point five point five. So this is a
new feature in one point five point five
where you could actually, like, set capabilities for
a registry. So I had to actually upgrade
continue to one five five.
And it was just released two days ago,
and I was actually using the RC version
before it. So
check You're off my Christmas card list though.
I don't think he was in.
So if you delete this file, container d
would pick it on the fly, and the
image would get pulled. Just delete the file.
You don't even need to restart continuity.
I delete the
okay. I deleted it already. Yeah.
I'm gonna delete the pods, and then,
hopefully that's the last little surprise Noel has
left for us.
Are we done, Noel? Yes.
Yay.
It's up.
Alright.
Nice one, Noel.
But still there there too. I don't I
had no idea about that container d change.
No. I didn't know that. I think someone
tweeted about it or something, then I saw
red with the restarts and found it.
Alright. Last cluster then. You two are up.
Ah, I think that was the application is
working.
I had another ID based on 01/21,
and it was a hint from Rory, but
I didn't I wasn't evil enough to do
it.
You might want to check whether this is
also working.
The port forward,
there's one more screen
is here.
Okay. So now we connect to another cluster.
Yeah. Hold on. What
no one wants us to check. I have
one more little snarky stuff left there, and
you would be good to go.
That should be easy to yep.
Okay.
Back on we go. Alright.
Yep. It's a easy fix. So yeah.
So
Yeah. It's working. I failed to connect.
I created that. I clicked this.
Let's check the services and endpoints.
I'm out of the cluster. Let me connect
again. This is
no.
Join the session.
Yeah.
Okay. We have an endpoint.
Maybe check
Call DNS?
Let's I'll just do a change. It's much
easier rather than
letting you go down to the epic call.
Call DNS, twenty six hours. Yes. He did
change something.
Still do it from DNS because we it
was covered,
I mean,
in breadth and depth.
I didn't touch this? No. You didn't touch
that. You just modified the deployment.
Maybe.
Most likely the c m and d m.
Like, creation map.
DNS rolling update.
Oh, I'm assuming this dog goose shouldn't be
here. Goose.
Is that the right path, Nel?
Yep. That h c call file. That's the
DNS.
Alright.
Oh,
it's just Etsy d call file. There's no
DNS in there.
Thank you. And if you scroll down, you
can actually look at the original call like,
the modified call file.
Just take the volume bounce. You would get
an idea.
Alright. Minute, Rawkode.
I don't need to even delete it. It
doesn't matter. Yeah. It will update that file.
Yeah.
I see what you did. Okay.
Yeah. I just need a few cuddle patch
and that's it.
We may have to rotate the accordion f
parts.
Oh, it's probably because of the
you are just delete that hotspot also because
I think we had we haven't typed on
the
yep.
Call DNS.
Yeah. It's the your DNS. It goes to
the volume.
Alright. Yeah. That's it, though.
We go. Turning one.
I think we probably need to, like, delete
the port for it to pick up stuff.
I don't know how really the DNS starts
working.
Tell you what. I'll just delete the whole
cluster.
Oh, yeah.
Crash the I was actually trying to do
the
You know what? I'm just going we'll we'll
just ignore this. Let's move on to the
last cluster. Yeah. Let's ignore it. At least
that was the issue. It should have fixed
it.
Alright. We have we have time. Correct?
Yes. We have Yep. You you have twenty
four minutes to fix my cluster. I've I
I didn't make it too elaborate because I
wanted it to be a bonus cluster.
You know, I wanted to focus all of
our time on both of yours. So I
don't think it'll take you too long, but
if you need any hints, I will I
will let you know.
I've opened the session on the control plane.
You can both
join, and I'll just sit back and laugh.
Cluster.
Yep. David is going to have a lot
of loss today. This is the first time
I've broken a cluster session. Excited.
And it's really hard. All the experience of
all the bakers.
Yes. I
I I did respect Vale's wishes, and I
stopped
almost entirely to kube control. Almost.
Cool.
So my DNS hack. Right? I was actually
trying to do a DNS hijacking,
but that doesn't seem to work with CDM.
So I just left out that box. That's
why I just, like, went with the whole
DNS thing.
Alright. Let me connect them. Activity.
Activation.
What happened?
Oh, you might need to just refresh.
I did not.
Sorry.
It's okay. Deshaun is saying if you wanna
live on the bleeding edge of container d,
you can use 155
1555,
but you make a cut.
View control.
Get notes. Let's see if we have an
API server.
Yep. And it is timing. Oh, no. We
didn't
oh, no. We didn't export it properly. Right?
Oh, yes. Only at SQL where it is.
I did export it, but then you override
it.
Oh, I'm sorry. So
we are clustering ourselves here.
Yeah.
Okay.
But it takes a while.
Yeah. I think okay. Now it's cached now.
Now okay. I
like being on that site.
At one point, I actually thought of doing
some network shaping. Takes a while. Then I
got it. The second one? To get it
fixed.
Sorry, Nolan. I was speaking while you're speaking.
But it does take a while.
Let
me remove the cache, and let's see again.
Oops.
Do you want to take control, or do
you want me to take control?
You you drive. Go ahead. That's fine. Okay.
I just want to remove the cache and
see again.
Oops.
Go ahead. Go ahead.
Okay. And try again, but do it with
verbosity if you can do some verbosity.
Okay. This is going super fast.
I think it's going fine because the response
is pretty fast. It must be, like, some
I know.
Okay. So why container is creating?
Can you describe?
Know it's like, detect your cuddle get not,
and, like, panic forever.
Kevin is asking how evil I can be.
I haven't been too evil.
So it is all cube control?
Almost.
Okay. Let's check the network policies.
Oh, the API was
modified.
So at least during case, the same steps
like I did. Yeah. I sent the same
steps to my birthday, and I'm one in
the future just just for the.
Of my test clusters, I actually set the
time forward. No no restrictions only. That was
a bad idea.
Admission.
And
it looks fine. Can you go down?
Lives.
Just a second.
It's not lives. Oh.
I think it's healthy.
It's health.
Health.
I
I don't know. Is this? This is the
liveness.
And the other one is ready.
Ready. Just for rest of the I never
changed either of those just for the record.
I didn't change either of those.
Really? Oh, yeah.
Okay. Okay. Why is this look at the
request.
And 02:50PM,
that seems
fine. It's okay. 02:50 is okay. Oh, the
failure threshold is 24?
Is that, like, normal?
So after 24
failure threshold, we get something.
Yeah. I think that's fine. But but it
the bot restart, we didn't see that.
I'm assuming there is I
okay. Before checking this manifest, let's check if
there are restarts or something. Yeah.
Yeah. There is. Oh, yeah.
House snipled through.
The
scene's fine
for almost everything.
Let's get our facts correct first. So we
have a container creating, but it's not creating.
Okay?
And I think we have some slowness. Shouldn't
we worry?
Yeah. We have a slowness, which we should
So we need to figure out the slowness,
I mean.
Yeah. You you can't describe the project. Right?
You you don't know why it's not in
container creating.
Yeah.
I can do that.
Just before that, I'll just check whether x
c d is also fine.
And hundred m?
We can check from the notes. I think
it's a little bit low.
Let me just copy to at least, like
I just matter, I guess.
I'll just create it without any changes,
and
share this Yarekuddle.
Run time.
And point
units.
So which problem are you trying to solve
just now?
That's what I'm saying. We don't know the
problem. So the only problem we see is
the container are still creating.
And I think there is a slowness also.
Yeah. I'm working. Yeah. I I mean Let's
look at the slowness first.
So you have everything running sixteen hours.
S three.
Sending update to
Oh, look. Hi. Our Google namespaces.
Nice.
Oh, I had it in my notes to
actually install XNS controller and do something, but
then I thought it's, like, too much work.
Yeah.
I think you need to decide which problem
these wanna fix. I think you're both working
on different problems right now.
So pick which one you wanna fix first.
So there is a context that line exceeded
that's happening, and it says custom resource definitions
hierarchy list would be done. I don't think
this is an issue for now,
But we probably need to fix the alright.
Oh, okay.
He's laughing.
It's just nice being on the safe at
all. But but it's admission control. It's denying
all modification.
Oh, so it must be that admission control
is typing out, and then, like, it's set
up created policy is set to ignore, and
it's actually typing out. So that's why it's
taking a little bit there. Can you describe?
Sure. Let's
no. Can you describe the bot? Yep.
Ah,
it's better.
At parts, I hope it returns faster.
I actually knew that list. Thanks for sharing.
Wish it was something better.
That slowness is really killing me.
Yeah. I think the slowness was a nice
touch. I really enjoyed that. Does this happen?
Did I
Did Okay. Can we get events?
Oh.
I mean, it's a Oh,
it didn't get scheduled.
So
yes.
Let me check if the scheduler is running.
Yeah. It's running.
You start to get emails. Right?
Did you know events are stored as resources
in FTD and can be deleted?
Yeah.
They can be deleted. I think they get
deleted anyway, but after an hour or something.
There is a time for it. There is
a threshold by default. I've not left you
any events or logs. Sorry about that.
Really?
I can send oh, it's called validating web
config. Right?
Evaluating web config configurations. Yep.
It could can't they have anything like v,
w c, or something?
I need to resolve this timing problem first.
Yep.
Okay. That's good. Try the mutating.
This is so much fun.
It's good to enjoy once in a while.
I want to check the logs,
Noel.
The port? Okay. Yeah. Let's go. Yeah.
David said he deleted the logs,
but we can get them easily.
Yeah. So we need to restart. Okay. So
That was a cruel touch, I must say,
but I joined. No. It's okay.
You cannot get rid of the logs.
I
think we should just restart your play.
This
should do the trick probably.
Not yet.
You know when when you restart the Qubelet,
what happens?
You play the Ah, if you restart it
if you restart it quite fast,
sometimes it would actually cause issues with continuity
and, like, gives you weird errors. I just
learned it yesterday in the talk. So if
you keep on restarting QBlack, content will start
to, like, be errors.
Okay. So things are up.
Yes. Things are up, but I don't see
logs. They should start logging already unless he
changed all the logging.
Yeah.
Oh, it's a container deconfiguration?
So where's the configuration
for logging?
I think it must be the container d
configuration.
The back is
what is it?
Is it how do I know the files?
The back is query, is it? Oh, I
don't know the You can run container d
config dump to see the config.
Yep. Container
d.
P. A space Oh, I know. It's just
containerds. Yep. Config
config dump. A space dump. Config default.
Oh, you just started containerd. Yeah. Delete the
control c that. You're cool.
Yeah. It's config space dump, I think.
Space dump. Percentage one. Yep. So percentage one
is, the previous process.
And it's doing that. It's like time reading
the container data configuration.
No.
No? There's nothing in regards to
Okay.
Run container d sock.
I want to try something, actually. Find
var.
Oh, let's take a permission of that folder,
and maybe it's not able to write to
that container var log container d.
Okay.
That would be too easy now.
You You said that it would be too.
And let's add a
I didn't modify any attributes on that directory.
So just the permissions?
Yeah. It's just it's just permissions. I'll give
you the you you got it.
Yeah. So it's not able to write.
Yep. Where's the little log.
Ah,
yep.
Yep. It should have w two actually do
something in there.
See, sometimes it's the simple things.
Yes. We always ignore the simple things.
Not yet.
Yeah. I think restarting a easier.
Not
yet.
Yes. I got it.
Manager is up.
ABI server is
up.
Yeah. So because the log file can't be
created when the container starts, you'll actually need
to rotate all the pods.
But you don't Let it say I gave
you a head. You I don't think you
need the logs to fix the other two
problems.
Okay.
So what are the two problems right now?
What is something said about
I need to check.
I need just to check
anything
with minus v. Let's say Yeah. That one
should have done in the first place. But
okay.
Accept. This looks fast, and there is no
one? Okay. Let's try with
11.
11 is really
verbose. Wow. Okay.
So account application.
Q1820.
5. 9 Seconds.
Okay.
So
and
so
Should we check at CD help?
Have not touched the CD.
Okay. Thanks.
I wouldn't tell you. I want to
get AI resources. Is it AI resources or
get AI resources? Yeah. AI resources.
That is also yep.
I want to check these things.
What happens? It's taking, like
I think it's taking time.
So
the API server is, like, taking a long
time to respond.
One of the reasons could have been the
limits, but the limits
what are the default settings in there seems
fine.
So
thank god.
That was something that
I think
Jim did. Right?
Changing the limits.
Which is, what the hell is with the
intermittent slowness?
Wait.
Yeah.
No. No. I mean, slowness could be network,
could be disk.
I'm guessing it's network here,
But I wanted to see
I wanted to see
now it should be cached. So it should
be faster. It's not faster while it's cached.
How come?
Or some or some governance, some checking. But
we check the mutating hooks. Correct?
We check the mutating. We check the validating.
Couldn't find any mutating or validating.
It might be that,
like, a static
one rather than
oh, but I don't think we see the
mutating or that we should that talks enabled
in the manifest, so I think we should
be okay.
By default,
are they enabled? I don't know which version
you called it.
Oh,
yeah. This is something about the HNC,
hierarchical
namespieces.
So the intermittent slowness the is the one
thing that's I didn't do with cube control.
You promised, man. One thing is and it's
not broken, and I finished just slowed you
down. That's it.
Okay. Okay. Okay. So you're still not I
mean, the real problem is the container creating.
The slowness was just for my amusement. That
was all. Let's see if there are drops.
So
nothing. Okay. So it didn't put it.
So there is an alias. Is this normal,
the alias?
Yes.
Okay.
The problem
when you said the verbose control get pods,
it was there.
The verbose, the 11.
I I was there with seven too.
It's just subtle.
Okay.
Let's
yeah. Let's go one by one. Yeah.
Loaded from Etsy. Get
API version namespaces
default.
Okay. Request
header
looks fine.
User agent response status.
Now
setting didn't show us anything,
does it? It is Kubernetes admin comp. Yeah.
I wonder if the audience can see it.
The board, 6443.
This
is 6334.
Oh.
So did you set up, like, a IP
tables forward?
No.
It's a bit more sinister than that.
Let's look at the manifest and see which
part it's listening.
So
so do we have 643 or no?
No. Let's look at the cube control manifest
sorry. The API server manifest and see which
part it's also listening. Because this is working.
Right? That's the
Yes. Yes. That's better now.
So okay. Now how did how did you
do it?
Yeah. That should be some kind of, like,
a proxy or something that does support code.
Right? Yeah. It's a it's a proxy. Run
p s a u x.
Throttling proxy. It's Toxiproxy
with a 40%
toxic
toxicology on delays of two and a half
seconds or longer.
What's the name of the proxy? It's called
SE Linux.
SE Linux, man. I renamed it.
Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes.
Actually, we would have caught it if you
listed the process and look because this is
a devian system and there is no way
SE Linux could be in here. Oh, yeah.
I thought it would be a nice hint,
but then you got to like, if you
don't look at the Yeah. You never let
it do. Yeah.
Alright.
There you go. You fixed that. Okay.
So this is one issue. Now what's the
other issue? The the containers.
The containers are still
Yep. Loading. See. Okay.
So the con we have the containers still
creating, and this is create container error.
Kube scheduler.
Ah, scheduler.
And okay. So the scheduler has an issue,
the control manager also has an issue.
Okay.
Let's describe it.
So you can ignore the controller, ma'am. I
think we fixed that shit. You're right. Could
it just
Yeah. Got it. But it's okay.
I have to go watch it. Wow.
And
if Lewis is watching, please don't do this
for the next CPF.
Yeah. Cluster road binding.
Cluster road binding.
I have not modified any RPac policies.
Any roles. Oh, you haven't? No. This must
be, like, a static admission controller that must
be set up in the
manifest.
Just a second. Just a second. Just a
second. Yeah. So the error
so the error is saying error from server
forbidden limit ranges case is forbidden. Admission control
is denying. It is an admission control.
But the thing is that his that the
ABI server,
if we look at admission,
I have only node restrictions.
Okay. Node restriction is the cube plate to
cube ABI things. Correct?
Isn't
isn't the static admission part of the cube
plate config?
No. It's 20. It's 24 I don't know.
Yeah.
Yeah. I am not really I have really
old questions.
Oh, any plug mission plug ins always deny.
Yeah. So I figured if I just one
of the kills well, not cool. One of
the annoying things with the API server is
you can do admission these plugins separately. And
I figured if I just put it below
the bottom of the screen, you wouldn't notice
the second one.
Yes.
Yep.
Because I checked
that first time we opened it, I checked.
Okay. Let's give it a minute.
Yeah. Still not up. Oh, no. It's restarting.
Yep.
Okay.
Hey. It's up.
Yay. That's get the bots.
Let's delete it. I think we should probably
just delete. Yep.
Yes.
Oops. Too many olds. Too many else in
old.
Yep.
Do we have another surprise, or that's it?
No. No. That was it. You got them
all. That's a nice one. I love that
one. Oh.
Because it's cascading. You know? But it's strange.
It's not always been so it only applies
to oh, it only applies to create or
update operations. Yep. Because all gets Yeah. So
the limit range actually my idea first.
Go ahead. Yeah. The the limit range is
just one of those resources. I don't think
a lot of people know. I think Walid
was very fortunate to pick that up. I'm
not sure everyone else would have.
What do mean unfortunate?
No. No. I think you were I think
you're experienced saying there that you knew a
limit range was a thing. Like, I think
many people could have had no idea.
The intermittent It's that's what open shift exam,
actually.
The limit range is right. It's actually in
the syllabus of the open shift exam. So
I have played with it, but it does
as a curriculum, then I I never did
it in any actual systems or anything. It's
anything, but I think no one really uses
it.
You got a a well done from Deshaun
there.
So yeah. There was And when I was
actually more breaking the cluster, one of my
ideas was when you do a GET, I
was thinking, like, of doing a GET your
dating report, but I didn't realize that we
couldn't do a GET on the rotating report.
I was actually, like, showing you the right
image, but it was actually running around image.
Yeah. I mean, I mean yeah.
Let me go with it. One
thing that I'm happy today is that we
made David happy as Lewis said.
Yep.
He has been miserable with this cluster thing,
but now I think today he's happy.
You know what? I I think we all
did really well. I think it's three broken
clusters, all broken slightly differently. We all stuck
mostly
to the cube control plane, which is nice.
We got to explore a bit more depth.
I think that was a good job all
around.
And we didn't really
kind of finish it in time too, so
it's actually good.
Yeah. We're only a little bit over,
so all good for me. Yeah. A little
bit over. And if it has not been
all the stuff I did, I think, like,
if I just stick with
probably, like, remote IP tables on the bot
for, we would have probably finished it in
time.
Alright. Awesome. Well, thank you both for joining
me for part one of this KubeCon special.
There's two more parts. We've got Thomas Stromberg
and Chris Nova joining me this evening. And
tomorrow, we have Gifei and Chris Carter.
Chris Carter. Wait. The second one is today?
It is. It is in a couple of
hours. Yes. Yeah.
So I'm I'm gonna let tomorrow. Cool.
I'll let you get back to Cape Cod.
Thank you for joining me again. That was
absolute fun. I will see speak to you
soon. Thank you. Thanks, everyone. And I'm happy
Thank you for having us. Bye. Thanks, everybody.
Bye bye.